el líder de samsung y jason ha salido de
prisión donde se encontraba recluido por
corrupción tras recibir un indulto del
gobierno que ha vivido profundamente a
la sociedad surcoreana a su salida de
prisión y se ha disculpado ante los
medios por haber generado inquietud al
pueblo surcoreano y ahí mismo en la
salida de la cárcel se han congregado
también personas tanto a favor como en
contra de su puesta en libertad aquellos
en contra consideran que la decisión de
indultarlo contraviene la promesa del
actual gobierno del presidente muniáin
de luchar contra la corrupción
-aquellos a favor de su indulto en
cambio subraya en el peso que tiene su
figura la del líder de una empresa que
genera la quinta parte de la riqueza
nacional de hecho el propio gobierno
surcoreano ha hablado de interés
nacional al argumentar a favor del
indulto que le correspondía ahí puesto
que ya había cumplido el 60 por ciento
de la pena de dos años y medio de cárcel
a la que fue sentenciado el tribunal que
lo juzgó lo encontró culpable de haber
pagado durante años sobornos a la red de
extorsión creada por la ex presidenta
surcoreana para kun y su socia es un sil
conocida como la rasputín